hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen bereitet seinem neuen video
vielleicht wisst habe ich vor einigen
wochen schon mal ein video hochgeladen
wo ich instagram bilder nachgestellt
habe falls er es nicht mitbekommen
verlinkt ich das einfach mal und in der
beschreibung und ich zeige euch immer
ganz kurzen ausschnitt davon beine sind
schon sich sind schon sehr gut
dann brauchst du jetzt berichtet habe
ich auf jeden fall super hingekriegt
finde ich da das video bei euch halt
super gut ankam habe ich mir gedacht
waren teil 2 freut euch alle mit mir
oder nicht oder das erste hitzacker
bildbasierten abstellen möchte ist
dieses bild hier von caspari das ist
einem youtuber aus london er sitzt
sollte irgend so einer muschel und hat
mit weg um sich rum
ich habe gerade beides hier nicht am
start ich habe so eine art setzte jetzt
hier gefunden eine decke habe ich nicht
genau die gleichen die jahren aber ich
nehme einfach mal meine zu decken vom
bett weil ihm cook das linke bein raus
und auch er die decke um sich herum ein
paar sekunden später also irgendwie so
um sich herum das rechte bein komplett
verdeckt das linke guckt ein bisschen
raus und dann hat er die decke irgendwie
sohn den händen und jetzt muss ich noch
irgendwie so bescheuert in die kamera
gucken also ich glaub ich glaube dass
mal so ein
als nächste stelle ich dieses bild hier
nach das sind lisa und lena das sind
beim musical die relativ krasse leute
also das sind zwillinge wie soll ich den
zwillingen nachstellen hierfür muss ich
erst mal die kamera ein bisschen weiter
runter setzt und ein bisschen mehr auf
augenhöhe positioniere die übrigens nur
die linke nach machen also das was ihr
hier jetzt eingeblendet seht weil ich
kann halt nicht beide nach machen weil
ich mich nicht einfach aufteilen kann
sie haben auf jeden fall eine brille in
den haaren das heißt ich werde mir meine
brille jetzt einfach mal so hier oben
reinschieben sie guckt so ein bisschen
hoch so mund auf ich hoffe dass so ein
in treue zu
das hier ist ariana grande
ich glaube die wir zu ausgesprochen ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher die sitzt auf
jeden fall auf einer treppe so nach
hinten gelehnt und ich habe auch keine
treppen in meine zelle eine treppe habe
ich mir vor machen mein gott das halt ja
richtig hier also sie sitzt irgendwie
und lehnt sich dann hier so anguckt
irgendwie so oder so der kamera deine
hängen ein bisschen gekreuzt
hier so die hände füße und kopf zur
seite ich kann meine klamotten nicht
perfekt treffen weil ich die klamotten
ich habe mich aber nicht so lange habe
ich auch keine ohrringe
ich glaube ich glaube dass so ein ich
bin relativ zufrieden hier wird das hier
ist der freund von babys beauty palace
der sitzt doch wegen der maurer ich habe
natürlich auch keine mauer in meinem
zimmer aber ich versuche ihm wie auch
immer der tv komödie zu machen also
julia ist hier auf einer mauer ich muss
das jetzt gab mein profitieren weil ich
keine mauern meinem zimmer habe sondern
ganz schön robust diese tv kommune also
hände irgendwie so zusammen festhalten
dass einem ein bisschen so dass andere
natürlich ihr unter bauern haben jetzt
natürlich ganz gut darstellen aber dann
irgendwie hat eine sonnenbrille auf eine
fresse jetzt muss ich wieder aufstehen
sonnenbrillen sah die ganze scheiße hier
nochmal durch hassen also klar die
hätten irgendwie so und jetzt irgendwie
ist das gut so ich das kann man so
einloggen
ihr kennt ja alle das ist max und ich
wette dafür denkt jetzt einfach mal nach
draußen geht um das irgendwie versuchen
nachzustellen also draußen in der natur
sind wir angekommen
max von der seite abgebildet natürlich
kein handy nach hand im gegensatz
die kamera muss ich echt mal feurig die
einen stellen einen bei ein bisschen
weiter unten die hände zusammen gefallen
dann irgendwie so nach vorne schauen
luca du kannst du schon einloggen
das ist julian berg und wie ich das
nachstellen soll weiß ich nicht
wie soll ich das nachmachen waren also
ich muss mich auf jeden fall schon
irgendwie so hingehen die füße ihnen
dieses zu euch verschiedene bett vor
allem süßes wie hoch denn irgendwie so
gucke ich nicht drauf kamera also
irgendwie so und jetzt probe den füßen
irgendwer
jetzt habe ich mein letztes welt mir den
ganzen kissen von mir komplett zerstört
und es war so schön hergerichtet die
kriechtiere kissen übrigens in kabine
château de das hier ist ein model namens
electric ich weiß auch nicht wie ich das
hier darstellen soll aber ich versuche
es einfach mal ich meine hier kann man
glaube ich nicht viel auch die arme sind
ordner mit drauf ich hoffe das passiert
so mit der kameraeinstellung also ich
rutsche quasi komplett nach hinten damit
die arme gefahr
sie hat die das gemacht haben sind vorne
auf jeden fall so schön oder kreuzt der
kopf irgendwie hier so rüber mit denen
pro wird rausgestreckt kopf hier drüber
und ich glaube das müsse so relativ gut
aussehen also luca 326 picture der reihe
nach stellen werden tun ist justin
bieber mit seinem hund ich weiß nicht ob
ich irgendwo ein plüschtier hab aber ich
stelle das jetzt mal nach justin hat
zwar keine sonnenbrille auf allerdings
auch nicht brauchen muss habe ich leider
nicht gefunden aber simba von könig der
löwen den habe ich hier noch das heißt
er kommt irgendwie in meinen arm oder
irgendwie so sehr bei ihm der hund kennt
hier irgendwie halt und ich als gast an
guckt den an muss man natürlich noch
irgendwie diese cap auf setzt das ganze
aussieht wie justin ja also ich glaube
der hund noch ein bisschen weiter
hierhin bzw sind wir ja in meinem fall
so ist eigentlich recht gut oder
das hier ist ein model namens london
blake
die sitzt auf ihrem bett und es halb
nackt deswegen dürfe also rechts
ausgestreckt dann links hoch gedrückt
irgendwie so dann macht sie mit der
rechten hand gegen die idee mit der
linken hand was sie sich so hierhin die
goldene kamera
genau hier ist relativ kulant ich
versuche es noch ein bisschen
verführerisch zu gucken
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe ich habe euch
unterhalten können wenn ich das getan
habe dann abonniert main kanal der ist
das abi zu verklickern make me happy
lassen wir den dritten teil haben wollte
und schreibe mir die kommentare
instagram falls sie jetzt noch dran seid
ihr findet meine instagram seite und in
der beschreibung und musikalität und so
sei auch alles drin also haut rein